[Musica]
la storia di cui oggi vi voglio parlare
è una storia di sport ma non dello sport
fatto di vittorie non dello sport fatto
di chi è arrivato prima di classifica ma
lo sport fatto il che genera positività
e cose positive per gli altri uno sport
che probabilmente poi giudicherete voi
ci dà la forza e la forza per andare
avanti la forza per credere io sono qua
in questa foto al sto correndo sto
correndo si perché corro mi piace
correre qua mi trovavo in media durante
la prima tappa di un viaggio lunghissimo
un viaggio fatto di 104 km che poi sono
diventati 106 neo aggiunti due perché
centro quattro erano troppo pochi
none raggiunti nei aggiunti due perché
il 6 e un numero importante e 6 è un
numero che ritornerà in più momenti
lungo questa storia
e qui sono io sono io alla fine di
questi 106 km con tutti tutti i
concorrenti che invece che correre è
invece che essere preoccupati nel
arrivare i primi o arrivare ultimi
arrivavamo tutti insieme dopo questi 106
agognati km
il viaggio è la difficoltà iniziata già
subito dai primi giorni siamo atterrati
a windows che è lì in alto all'interno
della mappa e dopo sei sette ore di
viaggio è abbastanza difficoltosa siamo
arrivati nel deserto del namib è
intasato più vecchio del mondo
il deserto bellissimo un deserto con
delle caratteristiche particolari per
cui l'ho scelto per questo tipo di gara
e con un'altra casualità il pettorale il
pettorale che mi è stato insegnato il
numero 6 ancora questo sai che torna è
un numero importante e un numero
importante per me
questa è la prima è la prima tappa è la
prima tappa nella gara
la prima tappa è una tappa notturna una
tappa di 15 km quindi molto semplice si
fanno 15 chilometri tutti noi no li
facciamo durante durante i nostri
allenamenti però il deserto e la in
generale la corsa un po come la metafora
della vita novo iniziato a fare delle
cose
poi durante la vita succedono gli
imprevisti e anche nella corsa succedono
gli imprevisti però se vuoi portare a
termine una sfida una gara sia che sia
col tempo si sa che sia per fare
qualcosa di bello
devi comunque andare avanti e sapere
reagire c'è sempre la possibilità di
reagire e io la prima difficoltà l'ho
avuta dopo tre chilometri sono un
pronuncia
pensavo che fosse così pazzi da tutti mi
ha sopportato e fatti così sembra faccia
a faccia ok io non mollo mai
esatto non potevo mollare non potevo
mollare perché perché questa gara era
associata un'iniziativa importante
diffondere easing
un'iniziativa importante per aiutare dei
bambini
un'iniziativa importante per raccogliere
fondi per la lotta contro il
neuroblastoma neuroblastoma un tumore e
un tumore infantile che purtroppo
affligge tantissimi bambini io prima di
questa esperienza non ne conoscevo
fortunatamente l'esistenza
però purtroppo ce ne sono tanti tanti
che anche in questo momento stanno male
e quindi il mio obiettivo era fare
questi 106 km raccogliendo fondi per
dare una speranza a questi bambini e
quando si corre nel deserto è complesso
ancora del deserto perché c'è la sabbia
fa caldo molto caldo nel deserto del
namib a dicembre alta stagione sicure
come 61 gradi
e vero che correre a 60 gradi non è come
correre a 61 gradi con lo so certo a
livello di umidità che abbiamo noi però
sono sempre 61 gradino durante la tappa
maratona di 42 km che è durata per
quanto mi riguarda sette ore di corsa ho
avuto diversi problemi non ha le braccia
di bruciature escoriazioni ma andava
bene così perché perché dovevamo portare
avanti la nostra gara quando si corre si
è soli o quasi in questo era all'inizio
della seconda tappa quella un po più
lunga è di 21 km quindi nulla di
drammatico però era una tappa
la bella una tappa che ha cominciato a
farmi pensare
una tappa che ha cominciato a svelare
anche la secchezza del terreno il calore
no che c'è in un deserto
il deserto comincia e mi ha insegnato
tantissimo mi ha insegnato che noi molto
spesso per essere ci sentiamo anche
durante tutte le nostre giornate durante
tutte le nostre attività lavorative dei
vinci b lin o ci sentono invincibili ci
sentiamo potentissimi però purtroppo nel
deserto ci si accorge che sei un puntino
e un puntino magari dove attorno a te e
io corso con 15 20 km dove non c'era
nulla e quando corri a 15 20 km dove
attorno a te non c'è nulla ti rendi
conto quanto siamo piccoli e ti insegna
anche che le cose della vita belle non
sono solo il cellulare un vestito
all'ultima moda assolutamente molti
ragazzi per essere contenti devono avere
il cellulare non all'ultima moda e lidi
ho imparato tante cose da un ragazzo che
guidava un autobus un pulmino e a un
certo punto in mezzo al deserto una sera
che andavamo a mangiare si è fermato
scende dal pulmino c'è la finanza a
questo deserto scendeva a prendere una
foglia da un cespuglio c'è la porta
questa foglia e ci dice siamo annusati
annusate questa voglia e questa folla
era una foglia di salvia lui era
contento perché con la sala del non so
se lo sapete profuma e non so se lo
sapete che con la salvia io posso fare
da mangiare e non so se lo sapete ma con
la salve io faccio anche le medicine
lui era contento per la salvia ora non
dobbiamo essere contenti
probabilmente solo per la salvia e
giusto essere contenti di tante altre
cose ma è importante anche a volte
valutare bene quanto siamo fortunati noi
il deserto della namibia è il deserto
che io ho scelto perché perché
all'interno del deserto del namib esiste
la ad una più alta del mondo più di 300
metri e quando sei la noi l'abbiamo
fatta di corsa o quasi di corsa lo
vedete lì sulla punta la bandierina che
poi si scendeva dall'altra parte è come
se toccasse il cielo no perché perché
nel deserto non esistono nuvole e quindi
quando sei line altro è una cosa
incredibile
salire sulla duna non è semplice io
correvo poco anzi camminavo molto e
quando quando sono arrivato sulla punta
della duna ero ormai al chilometro 100
mancavano solo sei chilometri
siamo ormai al chilometro 100 e che
corrisponde anche all'adunata più alta
del mondo quella media e ce l'ho fatta
adesso scusate ultimi 4 km ma le
facciate 2 andando bene sono contento in
internet grazie a tutti che mi state
danno forza
vado fi
aveva e io nel deserto trovato anche con
una citazione anche stamattina si
parlava del piccolo principe mio posto e
ho trovato tante persone che con me
hanno condiviso se non altro le 26
persone perché è una gara molto contante
i contendenti no20 sera una intesa 26
persone che hanno corso come alla fine
gli ultimi due chilometri potevano anche
non farli perché la sfida era di 104
hanno corso e all'arrivo sia realizzata
una magia una magia incredibile in
verità erano tutti molto agili non
durante la partenza perché le gambe
erano un po rigide e quindi questi siamo
noi perché l'organizzazione che cosa
aveva fatto un chilometro di distanza
dalla riva aveva messo quella bandierina
per darmi la possibilità di arrivare
finire la gara ufficiale poi tornare
indietro fare l'altro km poi ritornare
indietro per arrivare a 106 perché
perché il progetto aveva l'obiettivo
appunto di arrivare a questi n km ed
avere all'interno in numerose un numero
6 sembrano importante e ricorrente
la cosa interessante che noi siamo
arrivati alla fine e la raccolta fondi e
la raccolta fondi è terminata e
raggiunto il suo obiettivo il 20
dicembre del 2016 che se voi prendete le
cifre sono esattamente le cifre che
fanno 106 km oppure 106 x 2 212
ma io non ero così è non ero così quindi
non è che c'è speranza per tutti e non
vi preoccupate potete correre anche voi
ero così forse anche un po di più avevo
40 chili in più
non ero molto sportivo fumavo avevamo
anche capita alla gente di fumare è
sicuramente facevo 100 metri e e
facciamo già fatica non ero solo scusa
[Applauso]
oltre oltre avere una moglie che basta
avanza avevo avevo due figli uno un po
più grande riccardo che ormai ha 17 anni
e l'altro pietro che aveva sei anni e
pietro e riccardo qua durante il giorno
di scuola quindi tre anni differenza
questo è il primo giorno di scuola e
niente riccardo dove andare in quarta e
pietro in prima elementare quindi grandi
non so perché riccardo facesse pollice
in su e pietro pollice giù
evidentemente aveva già capito è la
situazione però purtroppo la vita a
volte ci riserva le cose le dure non
della vita cioè è un po come la corsa
quello che vi dicevo prima alla fine la
fatica a volte devi devi sapere reagire
e questo è quello che è successo questo
è un emorragia celebrale
questo è un emorragia celebrale
che la fotografia di un'emorragia
celebrale
purtroppo pietro ha avuto un'emorragia
celebrale durante a novembre durante i
primi giorni di scuola
e questa emorragia cerebrale è stata
causata da una malformazione artero
venosa che non sapevamo
durante durante la nascita e ha lottato
ha lottato duramente questa è l'ultima
volta che lo vedo sorridere quando
quando sembrava quando sembrava che
tutto andasse bene il 18 febbraio del
2010 purtroppo ci hanno chiamato e ha
avuto un infarto
perché era troppo stanco ok e quindi la
gara si chiama taran 106 dietro avete
capito no
il numero 6 il chiaramente non non non
voglio dare un'impressione brutta ma in
questi momenti non bisogna abbattersi ma
bisogno
ma bisogna continuare contenuti
continuare per dare comunque la forza a
chi è rimasto perché ricordatevi che i
problemi sono sempre di che rimangono ea
riccardo continuare andare avanti nella
vita e dare la possibilità agli altri
due che sono arrivati è arrivata emma
emma arrivata il 29 giugno san pietro e
successivamente è arrivato michele 18
mesi dopo quindici sono loro
bisogna assolutamente essere positivi e
anch'io non poteva battermi è quindi
assolutamente ho dovuto fare che cosa
riuscire a crearmi o migliorare no la
mia vita a migliorare la mia forma
non solo dal punto di vista diciamo così
visivo ma soprattutto dal punto di vista
fisico per poter dare la forza alle
persone no
e per essere io più forte e quindi ho
cominciato a correre
la prima immagine che vedete a sinistra
è la mia prima mezza maratona
all'interno dell'arena di milano e poi
un'altra arena un anno dopo la prima
maratona all'arena di verona bellissima
e fino ad arrivare a questa gara fino ad
arrivare appunto al deserto della
namibia dove appunto questi 106
chilometri mi hanno portato a vincere
questa medaglia ma ad aiutare tantissimi
bambini che avevano bisogno e vedetevi
la maglietta quella il simbolo io ce
l'ho tatuato addosso ed è sono io e te
sono pietre per quello che volevo
raccogliere 21.200 euro che ai 212 per
due perché io non ho corso da solo
all'interno del deserto e continuerò non
correre da solo quest'anno a novembre
andrò nel deserto dell'oman e il km
saranno 165 quindi anche qua ci sono
delle combinazioni dei tanti 6 165 km
totalmente in autosufficienza
quindi mi daranno sull'acqua vediamo e
speriamo di arrivare fino alla fine ma è
il deserto è diverso ma l'obiettivo è
sempre il medesimo cioè riuscire a
raccogliere i soldi per aiutare dei
bambini e aiutarli a fare stare meglio
il messaggio quindi che vi da oggi è un
messaggio importante
qualsiasi sia le difficoltà che noi
possiamo avere
grandi o piccole che siano c'è sempre
una speranza per tutti per fare
grandissime cose e per andare avanti
perché la vita un po come la mula
rotella no
[Applauso]
e oggi noi siamo qua è oggi è il 17 6
del 2017
tre volte sei vedete voi come come
volete interpretarlo grazie a tutti
[Applauso]